uh let's go ahead and check this out
well no you don't even know what it is
it's cnn see what's on the left-hand
screen
i thought you'd be progressing what's on
the right-hand screen um
so uh this was um i think
cnn's and uh new york uh
new year's eve show that they had and uh
here's what happened
i gotta tell you something i love when
you come on my show
and you bring some of the good herb with
you and i
he loves when he comes on the show and
snoop dogg brings the good herb can i
you you don't like good herb
do you think this like reflective quiet
times where
snoop dogg's alone and he's like
he's sort of like unsatisfied with the
box
that he's built for him to live in like
he's sort of
stuck in this like place of
he's just the weed guy he's like the low
rider weird guy like
like nobody respects him
[Music]
the way he probably wants to be
respected on some level like there's got
to be that
i'm just the weed guy like i'm always
going to be the fisheezy my heezy
you know ah you know what i like when
you bring the uh the dope herb
i like that a lot guy like he's gotta
like this
it's been [ __ ] with 30 years in this
now it's like the guy who plays [ __ ]
hank
in breaking bad can only play a cop uh
you know you get pigeonholed into doing
one thing and that's all you are
i get it but being he could play dea
guys forever or whatever but
it's still different than no it's not
even like hey this guy's like
a modern-day huggy bear like he's
literally that's all he could be there
like well you played huggy bear in stark
skin hutch
the movie but he's basically like a
modern antonio fargus like it's the same
he's like uh you know he is he's like a
black chong
like cheech reinvented himself cheech
did the
terrible was that golf movie kevin cost
tin cup tink up
did tin cup he did uh that that terrible
show with don johnson
that ran for the dash bridges he did
that for like but like
cheech ended up doing like [ __ ] without
chong
that it's just so that he could show
like hey i'm just more than just a bong
and a pair of suspenders like i want to
do something else
but like this guy he's like chong it's
like chong's still doing the
chong's like 70 and he's like hey weed
man you're like dude you're like my
grandfather's age
like it's embarrassing i gotta tell you
something i love
when you come on my show and you bring
some of the good herb with you
and i want to play a game with you look
it's okay
i'm sorry i need you to look at snoop's
face
because i know it's hard to get past
what he's saying look at snoop's face
when he hears
the good urban there's about a one
second delay obviously reading the talk
watch noob's face
i'm on my show and you bring some of the
good herb with you
and i want to play a game with you um
because
you're so upfront about
your uh smoking okay but it's so
legal now nobody cares yes
edgy trust me [ __ ] snoop was cool
in 1993 when he would roll up to the
grammys
and the entire red carpet was just
started smelling like weed
because there was something to be said
about
the certain kind of like swagger took
for like a crapper to be like yeah we're
going to the grammys
roll up with 50 of his boys and just
have weed smoke pouring out of the car
and be like what's up
like there was something cool about that
because you're like wow this dude don't
give a [ __ ]
but it once the first the second and the
third time it happened and the fourth
time it happened
even before weed became legal it still
became very commonplace
uh in in the circle of like hollywood
and the grammys and stuff so
after the after the first few times
snoop did that the gimmick wears off
like
how how many times is they gonna go bro
snoop
smoked a whole blunt like he didn't even
give a [ __ ] bro
dude we we did road rage tampa everyone
was smoking pot
openly all over the place everywhere we
went where people not just going
here's cool and you're like yeah it's
fine and we just walk down
everyone was smoking weed nobody cares
anymore it's not cool
i want to play a game with you called
have you gotten hi
there okay i'm gonna run through various
locations
literal mike i want you to look so
people don't think i'm lying
literal douche chills i got literal
douche chills
oh my god i am tingling oh my god that
was so bad
i might imagine
imagine instead of snoop
that this was patrice o'neill
that was there at this event
imagine imagine look i'm trying to just
close my eyes and picture
patrice being there instead and watching
his
watching his mood sour like remember
when patrice would like
furrow his brow and be like like
and you could just tell he was
activating his weapon system
like i've just i was like god i wish
patrice was still alive and being like
first of all what is this a little
[ __ ] jewish guy
coming at me asking me about smoking
weed like like dude it's so
this whole thing is so forced remember
dude when i was up there for christmas i
was uh talking to my family about how
at this point i would even take ryan
seacrest back and of course my family's
like yeah but you hate ryan seacrest i'm
like
yeah but at least he was just an empty
suit right
that was there to sell products and
introduce the next musical act
now they're getting these like slimy
media types to come in and do it
and they don't have a pers like ryan
seacrest doesn't have a personality
either
but ryan seacrest's entire personality
is being able
to fake having a personality so he at
least fake it here's what it is you're
right
ryan seacrest doesn't have a personality
he doesn't have also doesn't have an
agenda
he's nothing but like zach brought this
up it's a really good point these are
the same people on the left that are
telling
us to bomb iran like these are the same
people
that are telling you that you are not a
good person
and not only the bomb iran thing but
there's this
because of the agenda they have these
guys are always so desperate to be cool
they'll be down with the kids so they're
trying to be cool with like
snooping right and just 60 year old
black
it's 2003 by the way it looks like your
grandfather at this point
um but it it it's and by the way i
guarantee if you want the most young
black men right now that are into hip
hop and you went yeah snoop dogg they'd
be like
man from soul plane they wouldn't even
know about me as a career
you know but like you're right they'd be
yeah i remember that with kevin hart he
did that song did he do a song with
migos
i don't you know kodak black
so he's like but they have this agenda
so they're always trying to like be like
we're down with the
brisone or whatever they're doing don't
say that even joking i can't
please that's never true i get it i know
i get your point they're trying to do
you ever said to me again
so um but
the whole thing is like they have an
agenda or whatever
but because of that they're trying to
attach themselves to things like snoop
dogg and be cool
the reason why i would take ryan
seacrest back is because ryan seacrest
never tried to be cool he never
like he did look to seacrest's credit
i know he's a generic [ __ ] and most
people hate him
but he nobody in this generation
is more of a broadcasting pro than ryan
seacrest
he puts his talks on he shows up give me
the notes
all right we're ready to go let's do it
three two one and he does whatever the
sells whatever product they tell him
introduces whatever next musical act is
but he doesn't try to outdo the [ __ ]
show he doesn't try to be the star of it
it's not like um it's the same way with
like dick clark
and there's plenty of other guys that
would go just give me the notes
i'll go out there i'll do my job and
professional host yeah
professional host so it wasn't like yeah
i'm gonna drink too and smoke weed
am i right snoop dogg like ryan seacrest
would be the first one to be like never
touch the stuff
like can you go god damn that's nerdy
but you know what that's
kind of what i miss about my dick clark
types yeah be like never touch the stuff
sorry been married to the same woman in
the same lutheran household for 50 years
and we all know he's actually probably a
closeted
guy but it's like you know just do that
just just be what i need you to be
for this yeah and i want to know if you
have gotten
high in them okay all right snoop
i like that have you gotten high uh yeah
i do too
have you gotten high on a yacht
i have got high there
yes i know the answer to this one cause
you talked about it on watch what
happens live
by the way that's literally like asking
have you ever gotten high in a car
yes hey have you ever gotten high in
your home
i'm poor and i've gotten higher yeah
yeah yeah i live in florida to be fair
enough since yes but even on long island
you'd end up on a yacht somewhere
smoking weed
but like it's like asking if you've ever
smoked weed
like hey hey snoop have you ever smoked
weed like
on a sidewalk of course
that's like asking somebody a long line
remember got high in the basement with
their cousin
the answer's going to be yes you're
right yes
have you ever been high in a basement
apartment
yeah have you not no can i where do you
think i
buy my weed from again florida being the
only answer where you go no it's never
happened but on a yacht yes but only due
to a
distinct lack of basements but you just
replaced basement with garage apartment
in florida and it's the same thing
but the white house if you're gonna hide
the water and you do
know that yes yes yes yes
okay have you gotten high at martha
stewart's house
what is happening just let me handle
this answer would be
y e s yes yes yes
did you get martha high did you get
martha hi
i will say this the only thing i do like
about these new year's eve shows
is that they are slowly killing anderson
cooper's spirit
oh yeah slowly dying inside like you
understand he was a vanderbilt
he was raised to be the next
like walter cronkite the next dan rather
like this guy was
who liked butt stuff but yeah well
jerry's still out on some of those guys
too
um just look you don't get to be a news
anchor for 30 years in the golden age of
television and then them not have files
on you
i'm sure the boys had something going on
fair enough but like fair enough enough
this dude [ __ ] wanted to be he was
gonna be the voice of america
he was gonna be a [ __ ] tom brokaw
type
but because of the way america's been
dumbed down and watered down
even the people he has to rule over it's
like you could just tell this is hell
for him because
he's like one of those guys that was
still trained in the ways of the old
world
he probably placed five instruments
never touches a drop of alcohol
he's probably like 60 probably still has
abs like he's one of those weirdos that
just eats [ __ ] vegan food and just is
neurotic and has a vanderbilt
and it's like no now you got to hang out
with andy cohen and snoop dogg
on a shitty telecast that nobody's
watching nobody watching because
everybody's too busy watching
hunty live you know i mean like you're
losing your grip on
like imagine like you finally get to
take over as like one of the people
who's like gonna rule over the world
but now everybody's just so fat and
trashy that you're like uh you know what
i don't want it it's like when they
tried to give naaman to his [ __ ]
heroine back on the wire and he's like i
don't want it
i don't want it it just ran away
i have to say if if second hand smoke
counts
yes yes yes okay okay snoop
have you gotten high at a bar mitzvah
nah man i don't [ __ ] with those people
what if that
that man no comment i don't [ __ ] with
that for those people man
like i don't i don't really want to talk
about that all right you hear me
you know be really funny would be like
um
you could be like okay snoop i've got
one i've got one i've got one
uh did you ever smoke weed
in in that car that you and your
bodyguard murdered that guy
in huh yes yes
yes hell yeah i mean allegedly allegedly
now he'd be like no double jeopardy dog
you wouldn't believe me if i told you
what that answer is going to be
yes yes yes i knew it i knew it
because you were performing some rich
guy paid you
to perform at his kid's permission yes
and you were like some rich guy what
kind of rich guy
told me to do whatever you want to do
where am i right you got to love that
guy
i know that obviously they're joking
about the weed but it's like snoop dogg
somebody look snoop dogg does have a lot
of money he still does
believe it or not he actually is one of
those people that invested his money
well he did he invested his money while
he's always had money
but the fact that rich can still
pay you to because they gave paula deen
all this [ __ ] right for the whole
plantation stuff but what's the
difference between these
rich jews being able to have enough
money to pay snoop dogg
to play at their kids bar mitzvah you
know it's the same thing
it's the same kind of thing i
okay have you gotten high at an
nfl football game
yeah yes i have as opposed to an nfl
basketball game
an nfl baseball game what is this he's
just
is is this guy supposed to be there like
greg gupfeld their version of gretch
guthrie yes
that's what he is right he's supposed to
be terrible they're funny guy
yeah see a comic or something i don't
really know much about andy cohen except
for the last name thing all right snoop
snoop so so going back to your
uh alleged 1993 murder of philip walder
waldemarian um when he was at the park
did you and your security guard
follow him to the park or did he because
you said you didn't follow him but the
evidence suggests
that he did in fact follow
just keep making it awkward yes yes yes
all right enough of this i mean we we
get it uh
see now that would be comedy would be
just constantly blind signing him with
with questions about the man that was
killed in la 1990
you would have to sneak them in like
really just hardcore stuff did you ever
smoke weed
like before uh the verdict was right at
your murder trial
a man is dead and we're all sitting here
laughing
so when like switch and i told you he
was gonna get tupac killed
like did you were you high then hell
yeah
hell yeah i was the biggest thing on
death row two that [ __ ] tupac
came over hell yeah shook night kill
born
covey
[Laughter]
oh hi like what are you doing what you
can't say that on tv snoop
there's like dozens of people watching
you're gonna be
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
that's the kind of [ __ ] you get in
trouble for saying but i was a character
saying that i wasn't saying that
see it goes clinton's
then suge knight and then covey oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that was really funny man
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
god damn oh [ __ ]